today I'm talking about dask and shared
memory as you know and uh here's my
outline I'll be talking about dusk
that's distributed in particular and uh
frame the question that I'm setting what
is shared memory why does it have any
implications for desk and I'm going to
test it and then show you some results
and then talk about where that leaves us
so let's get stuck in task
um lots of you will know what desk is
but I'll give a a very brief
introduction for those of you that
haven't heard of it before so uh task is
a python library for parallel computing
and it enables you to work with a bunch
of different high-level apis
particularly data frames and arrays most
common but other things too like bags
which is uh generalized python iterative
functions delayed for any kind of
function calls machine learning library
there's a whole load of different things
that you can use with desk and what they
end up doing is creating a graph of
tasks that you want to execute and those
tasks are then executed by a scheduler
so you make your graph using normal data
frame like operations if you're using
the data frame API and then you say
something along the lines of dot compute
that will bundle up your graph it will
send it to a scheduler and a scheduler
will be in charge of executing that
thing and we'll be just talking about
the distributed scheduler here in which
case you're shipping the whole thing to
a different process and that control of
how things get executed will depend on
that process eventually things will run
on some workers and you get your results
back and because it's running on many
workers you get many times the CPU and
memory than you would have in a single
process
uh here is a sort of logical layout of
a desk distributed cluster
and you can see the client the client is
where you enter your commands where you
run your script or your notebook
whatever it may be that's your client
scheduler is the thing that decides when
things run and where and now the workers
are the ones that actually
run functions and produce results
so for example oh and I've put on some
lines here the the solid lines are
constant communication so the client
talks mainly with the scheduler the
scheduler talks to the workers the
workers talk to each other sometimes the
client can fetch results directly from
workers once those workers have produced
a result but that is is the less common
path
so uh here's an example I've just filled
in a few things on the background here
let's say I've done some data framing
thing and if the the result that I want
is
um the thing that the token key 3 refers
to so key three is some result
the client will say to the scheduler hey
I would like to have key three please
and uh here's the graph and now you can
see a simple representation of what
graph might look like it says that Keys
three requires some function which is
going to run on result key one and
result key 2.
now let's say that on your workers you
happen to have key one on one of your
workers and key to on a different worker
in that case obviously if you want to
run a function it depends on both of
those we'll either have to be of key 2
to be on the same worker as key one or
move key one to be on the same worker as
key two and when I say work here I mean
copy we're going to be copying and
sending that data between workers so
we'll have redundancy we'll have a
duplication of however much memory Q10
is using
okay
so that's how dask Works in a nutshell I
hope that wasn't too fast for people
again I'm expecting that a lot of the
audience here has actually used that
goodness makes some sense to you but I
do want to have a little aside about
deployment options for desk and there
are many of them and these are all
that's distributed deployment options so
in addition to the standard default desk
scheduler that works in a single process
you have a whole load of different ways
in front of you that you can create a
distributed cluster
you can have a cluster on a single
machine and in that case you will be
using each of your workers and your
scheduler and your client will be in
different processes but they will be on
the same machine at the most common way
to do this is to use the local cluster
this is the same thing that you get if
you just do client with empty
parenthesis then you get a local cluster
and it uses a number of workers on your
machine the number of workers depending
on your CPU cost
but there's lots of different ways and
people use task in all of these
different scenarios so you might have
access to a supercomputing resources and
be required to use a job manager like
these things that fortunately I don't
have to deal with but some people use
these things
um and you might be talking hundreds of
calls or more
um you might be using something that is
more familiar to data scientists these
days some kind of container architecture
kubernetes yarn maybe raw Docker
something else and that's something else
might in typically is then running
within another framework so your
container providing framework might be
in the cloud it might be on premises
there's a whole load of different
iterations that you might have
containers each of those containers
usually contains one task worker with
one or a couple threads is typical
then you might just have a bunch of
machines again you can do this very
simply in the cloud or you might have a
bunch of machines in in your lab or
whatever it may be
and each of the machines runs one or
more processes again and there are
various different ways to set these up
so you can there are back ends so you
could talk to the different Cloud
vendors or you might just have direct
SSH access to all of these machines
and there are managed versions of these
like that's Gateway and other various
commercial offerings to where you get
somebody else to create the cluster for
you and you get access
so these have come with lots of great
features for example if your CPUs are
all busy then maybe it will auto scale
uh provision more and more CPUs until
you can manage the workload that you're
dealing with
um they come with various uh
um compromises so start a time for
creating a cluster from from scratch
might be faster it might be slow
depending on exactly which one of these
you're dealing with and of course
whatever system it is you probably have
to care about
how do you get access to the system but
nobody else or how do you allow access
to other people and and all the usual
Enterprise things of
auditing who does what where and who has
permission to do these things
now I want to make one point clear and
this comes up in stack Overflow it comes
up on the issue tracker it comes up with
in all meetings that I I ever have about
desk the single most common thing that
causes a task workload to fail is a
memory error one of your workers at some
point is trying to use more memory that
is a than it is allowed to use and it
gets killed by the system where a system
might mean the container or it might
simply be that just there's no physical
memory available well and and you get an
exception either way memory errors are
by far the most common reason that a
desk workflow fails
so we really care about it
um you have some options when you create
these these different kinds of clusters
these are the typical things that people
will configure the number of threads per
process the number of processes how you
impose memory limits whether you spill
to disk whether you pause a workers
until it has managed to change through
some of the the backlog of tasks
the most common thing or the easiest
thing in many cases if you are hitting a
memory problem is to get more memory or
more specifically get a bigger machine
that has more memory available and maybe
distribute that across your containers
or whatever it may be
um I've highlighted Gail here that's
just to remind people that the choice
between threads and processes in Python
is very much dependent on The
Interpreter log so processes are good
because they each have their own
interpreter lock so they can run
efficiently in parallel threads are good
because different threads can share
memory so you don't undergo the
duplication penalty
okay so I've talked a lot about
different deployment options what about
the case where you just have one single
machine why would you want to do that
well there's actually quite a lot of
compelling reasons for this if you have
a single machine it's really easy to get
a desk up and running you don't have to
worry about
um once you have the machine going
however you started that machine all you
need to do is start some processes and
that's as easy as having access to the
machine at all you don't have to worry
about all these different Frameworks for
starting containers for submitting jobs
for starting other virtual machines
elsewhere and making sure that the
networking between them makes sense all
of that is well it just disappears it's
it's easy because it's not even a
problem you just have to be able to
access your machine that means if you're
going from absolutely nothing and you
want to get going with a dash cluster of
reasonable size you can spin up a
machine in a cloud and have desk running
in
pretty much seconds depending on
um how you want to actually install dusk
on that machine it can be really really
fast
and
these days this wasn't always true but
it's been true for quite a long time you
can get some seriously big machines so
if you do have something that requires a
lot of memory you can get a lot of
memory it's not a problem get the
machine hit starts up quickly run your
workload close the machine again it will
not cost you that much money
it's probably cheaper in many cases than
having a Das cluster available on auto
scale so it's always there even if it's
always there on a relatively small scale
um and having a machine that's twice the
size twice the memory twice the CPU is
actually twice the cost of having two
machines of that original size so uh the
the cloud pricing model makes this very
much a
attractable way to do things
and finally and this is this is not very
well appreciated usually
um if you're running in containers and
each container has four gigabytes of RAM
once you reach four gigabytes of RAM
you're stuck you either have out of
memory error or you spell disk you have
to take evasive measures you have to
change your workflow possibly which is
really painful
if you have a lot of processes on a
single machine they share their memory
pool
it may be that some of your workers need
way more than four gigabytes sometimes
but they don't probably all need a large
amount of memory at the same time so you
can make pretty efficient use of memory
like that and CPU you can over subscribe
in this case
all right so when processes talk to each
other this is the the kind of very uh
rough layout of how that happens you
have a process here which contains some
threads you have a process here which
contains some threads each of these
threads can see all of the memory within
the process but if you want to send data
from one process to another you're going
to have to make some kernel calls and
you have to do some kind of
serialization and transfer
serialization might be over the file
system abstraction might be of the
network abstraction or there are other
possibilities in desk it almost always
means TCP and network layer and the
reason is that this works equally
equally well between processes and a
single machine and between processes on
multiple machines so that's very
convenient but it's a loss of overhead
also it means that obviously if you do
that you duplicate the memory you had it
in the original one and you make a new
copy in a new one and you had to
actually pipe those bytes between
processes
as a Counterpoint shed memory looks
something like this you yes you still
have to make a call to the kernel at
some point but it's just going to
allocate you allocate you some Ram
somewhere in the system
this Ram can be made visible and in fact
mapped into the memory space of multiple
processes so this dashed line here from
process one this point of view it looks
like it's part of process one it looks
like it's just perfectly ordinary memory
but it in fact refers to this block of
memory over here and then process 2 has
the same thing it refers to this block
of memory over here so you don't copy
the memory all you have to do is make
sure that the data you're interested in
ends up here in this shared piece and
then all of your processes kind of view
that memory with no duplication and no
communication cost it sounds like a
really big win
um brief aside there's a couple of
mechanisms for making this happen a
classical shared memory positive shared
memory and memory mapping uh you don't
need to worry about the difference it
doesn't make any practical difference
for what I'm talking about here
okay so I thought for task
in the single node case it might make a
lot of sense to be able to not use TCP
to send large amounts of data from one
process to another but to use a shared
memory encapsulation
and here's a really sort of simplistic
uh code snippet that shows how I did
this and there's links to the repost for
those that are interested this is um my
Fork I've distributed where the actual
code that does this is located and this
is a set of of benchmarks that show how
well this did or didn't perform uh
essentially what I'm doing is at the
point at which desk is ready to send
data from one worker to another or from
the client to a worker we're going to
pass it through pickle and extract the
memory views the buffers from it and
each of those memory views we're going
to create a shared memory segment and
we're going to copy that buffer into
that shared memory segment then we're
going to remake the original object
using those buffers and discard the
original object so we very temporarily
duplicate memory as we do this copy but
then we drop the original object
immediately so now we have a new object
that depends on the shared memory blocks
instead
and those are what we pass after the
other workers so it can also recreate
the object based on those shared memory
segments
I'm using three backends for comparison
here lmdb
um arrow and Vineyard
arrow is the one that's used by Ray
there's been a lot of discussion in Ray
about whether they should switch to
something else like Vineyard I've put an
asterisk here because Vineyard is in
theory I haven't done this myself it
works entered node between nodes as well
so that might be interesting if you
wanted shared memory and you wanted a
networked
thing but that's not what I was
investigating here
okay
um some things weren't done and
particularly dask doesn't know that this
happened so desks metrics of how much
memory is used where will be wrong it
will also not know and not be aware that
it's copying things from one place to
another might be much faster than you
think it is and
um where should a task of the go
therefore will
be using the old system because it's a
lot of work to try and change that
okay the result so
and uh this is the only result site I'm
going to show I'm not showing you code
I'm not showing you live anything and
I'm not showing you tables this is it
so I found in short that if you're
scattering this is whether you're
scattering from the client to all of the
workers or from one worker to all of the
workers but you are explicitly calling a
replicate function I want this piece of
data to be seen by all of the workers in
that case you get exactly what you
expect instead of let's say you have six
cores six workers instead of having six
times the memory footprint of the
original object you only have one times
the footprint of the original memory
object and all of the other workers are
able to just view that object without
duplicating memory without spending time
on on transfer
excellent that's exactly what you wanted
however
on the other side when you try and apply
this to typical data frame and array
workflows and you can look in my repo to
see what I attempted to do that would do
this
I didn't get any Improvement in those
cases
these workflows are sort of uh overlap
be
re-indexy kinds of things
so data is definitely being shuffled a
decent amount
but we're not getting an improvement
from shared memory and finally and this
is a marginal result lmdb was perhaps a
little slower than the other two it is
does have the different technology
behind it um it maybe comes with better
ability to spill to disk because I said
file system based one rather than a pure
shared memory based one
um I I won't make much out of that
because it's it's only marginal not very
important from this talks point of view
Okay so
what's going on here
um we managed to get a really good
result but in the workflow case we
managed to essentially not get a result
and the real reason that this happens
well there's a couple of reasons so I'll
go through each of these and spend a
minute talking about what these mean
um dask really tries very hard to assign
work to the worker that already has the
data that it's going to need for that
task
that is it does everything it can to
reduce communication between workers and
to reduce duplication of memory uh this
is actually in the very latest version
of I've distributed this is even more so
the case memory management is even
better than it used to be so if task is
trying to not copy memory then having a
way in which copying memory is more
efficient than it used to be is not
going to be as obvious or as important
a second point and I mentioned this on
the things that I didn't get around to
trying or to developing
um dusk's idea of how much memory a
worker is going to need for a particular
task it will be wrong and it's in fact
quite tricky to
account for shared memory because no
particular process owns that memory so
how and and you can only release the
memory when all of your processes are
done with it
so it's difficult to say what's the cost
of starting a new task that depends on
some piece of memory what's the savings
from being able to release a piece of
memory those things are are now hard to
reason about so I didn't touch them and
ask will be getting this wrong it's
going to assume that when you need a new
copy of something that is already in
shared memory it's going to assume that
you need that full amount of memory
again and that's will not want to do it
it's also going to assume that the cost
of transferring it will be the cost of
original the the original serialization
where serialization meant copying it
into shared memory so it took some time
in the first case subsequent copies are
not going to take time there is not an
easy way in desk to take account of this
third Point might just be the most
important one here
if you have something that is in shared
memory and you take slices of it on the
python level you don't allocate memory
but you make a new memory view object
when you come to pickle this memory view
object you get a new buffer object there
is no way to know or at least I'm not
aware of a way to know that this new
buffer object is in fact part of a
different buffer object that is in
shared memory in other words
with this new buffer object we're going
to make a new shared memory
segment even though the data of that
buffer is already in shared memory I
don't know how to get around this maybe
some people here know away
uh finally and this is in practice what
I might might end up doing we know it
works well for scatter in the case where
we're explicitly replicating there's a
really obvious place that we can put
this in ignore the serialization layer
just make an object that replicates
itself using shared memory alone that
will be useful by itself it's something
that we can put straight into
distributed and it doesn't it you don't
need to worry about the rest of these
questions in that case because it will
be an explicit thing that you the user
knows they want to do
all right
um coming towards the end now here's a
summary
um
I'll read through these because I think
they're all uh moderately important
first thing is it's often overlooked
that single node workload is really
important uh whether you're doing it on
a laptop or a big desktop or you just
have a single virtual machine with hey
let's have a hundred cores and 200
gigabytes of RAM you can totally do that
and it's totally the right answer in
many useful cases and they come with
some advantages that I went over before
I won't repeat myself there
um but in particular if you have
something where memory is a problem you
can just get more memory for the
workflows that needs it you don't need
to redesign your cluster you don't need
to go back to the drawing board and
redesign your workflow and change your
chunking schema all those things
sometimes it's the right answer
um my experiments have shown that shared
memory does what you would like it to do
for when you're scattering specific data
sets between your processes that's good
but making it useful for a data free
data frame or array workflows if it can
be made to work would require
considerably more effort than I had time
to do here
and so the thing to take away here is
either somebody wants to push this
forward but in practice I'm going to
make the shared memory thing available
for scatter and replicate only
um and then an open question to the
people here from the ray Community Ray
has shared memory between processes
what'd you do with that how useful is it
how important is it what happens if you
turn it off I I would be very interested
to know
um Ray of course was
the thing that brought shared memory to
parallel processing in Python at least
to my notice and that is that was the
whole spur for trying to do this thing
so I'll leave it there and we have about
five minutes for uh questions thank you
very much
oh thank you so much for your talk
Martin uh
have any questions from the crowd
oh
uh anything else you'd like to add Mark
oh thank you Carlos
no questions but you are awesome
yeah I've got yeah I've gotten to know
several of the Anaconda people over the
course of the conference y'all y'all
seem pretty uh
pretty cool to me
thank you
I this this was fun and pretty much
outside of my
normal
uh steam house wheelhouse whatever
people say and not not the kind of work
that I normally do so they may well be
the people who understand these these
underlying critical things better than I
do could have gone further but nobody
else was working on it in the Das
community so I wanted to give it a shot